[Music]
hey welcome everybody
my name is Dave Payne from Alaska file
excited to be with you guys today we'll
be talking about POSIX file systems
enterprise class storage in Google cloud
I'm honored to be joined by a couple of
good friends here today we've got Naidu
a nominee from Alaska fire or from from
silicon and the and Dean Hildebrand is
joining us from Google hello my name is
Dean Hildebrand I'm in the office of the
CTO and one of my goals at Google is to
make file storage awesome in Google
cloud that is great all right well we
got a few minutes together today we're
gonna we're gonna jump in to some
high-level stuff and then we're gonna
get deep and go technical I assume
that's why you're here with a title like
this if this is attractive to you you're
a hardcore nerd and we thought we'd
serve up some meat in this session today
okay so let us get through a few slides
of intro then I promise we'll deliver
some some real demos in the middle of
this if the section and then in Dean and
Naidu we're gonna stand up and share
some of their perspective and real-world
experience doing this in cloud okay so
first of all there's a great concept
intact and you've probably seen floating
around for a while called yak shaving I
learned about this last year actually at
Google Google cloud next it's this idea
that it's it's we all get caught up in
it right a yak shaving is it's the you
start out to do something big and
important and then a day later you've
done everything else but that because
there's all these dependencies right
it's the last in a series of unexpected
steps I read it came from this idea that
you know rice harvesters were they would
go out to harvest their you know the
years of harvest and they'd used the
yaks to pull the carts in and out but
they'd find that the yak tore all this
hair in the middle of the winter and so
they couldn't fit through the gates so
we have to turn around go back and do a
bunch of yak shaving to get the yak
skinny enough to go through the gate
right and I've heard it said an IT
intact this is essentially what our job
is right does anyone shave yaks all day
long for a
I know I do in fact preparing this
presentation the demos included all the
water yack shaving for me so much so
that it may be an even bigger believer
in cloud it to be honest but you know
you actually even comes up in all of our
lives in different ways I was throwing a
party for my for my wife last year and I
ended up spending three weeks rebuilding
a deck right you go to buy the electric
car which I haven't done yet but as you
do you find out that you're now pulling
220 volt into your garage and it doesn't
quite fit and it's a big bunch of hassle
you say I'm gonna go have children you
have these amazing ideas of graduations
and weddings and it's just a you know
fantastic and then for 18 years it's
this and this and this and this and
finally they get tired after eating all
the Bologna right so that happens in all
parts of life and especially you start
to consider a move to cloud you know you
finally make that decision
a guy like nigh do as the CIO says we
got a mandate from our board our CEO
whatever we're gonna go all-in on cloud
or ready to make this happen he says do
you guys make it so and then you find
that hey changing infrastructure is hard
there's a lot of yaks that have to be
shaved to make the stuff that I
comfortably use inside of my data center
working cloud right there's uh
specifically in this talk we're gonna
we're gonna hit some of these issues as
it relates to applications that need
things like NFS which seems like a
simple mundane tried-and-true method of
accessing data but it's different
because everything in cloud is a little
bit different right
I can't just take mine as and put it out
there and work doesn't work that way the
fundamentals are different I need to get
my data out there well data formats are
different the files may be the same but
there's different ideas like object and
the like how do I get my data up there
upload it
keep the POSIX nature of the data the
same so lots of other issues come up and
that's what we'll start addressing here
today okay so we came together us you
know Dean and I essentially in our
respective companies to eliminate those
yaks that have to be shaved as you start
to make this intro in the cloud okay
we're good so today we're gonna cover
we're gonna cover again a little
more theory Dean's gonna come up in just
a second and tell you the perspective
the Googlers have on on NFS and cloud
we're gonna show you how some of the
stuff works demo it and then night who's
gonna be he's our headliner so you got
to stick around to seen I do he'll come
and show you real work that he and his
team have done and by the way some of
his team is out here we got we got David
and Jonas yeah praise your hand guys
they can't see on the video but they're
in the audience is any technical
questions come up they can answer it
they're experts all right so without
further ado I'd like to hand the mic
over to Dean Hildebrand and let him take
it away Dean Wright thanks Dave
alright so I wanted to just give a brief
intro on a few things one of just
talking briefly about file in the cloud
and as well as why does Google care
about file in the cloud alright so you
know here's the the typical scenario a
company is going to move into the cloud
alright this sounds awesome Google has a
bunch of data migrate application
migration tools alright let's move the
applications into the cloud next step is
well what do we do with the storage are
we gonna start from scratch or are we
going to rethink you know everything we
ever thought about storage does salt you
know the cloud solve all of our problems
what are we gonna do right so I think
that this becomes a general blocker in
many cases when you have terabytes to
petabytes or more data on premise and
you're just not sure on not only where
to store it but how to store it and how
your applications will will access it so
I think some of the the no-nose
generally are right there is no one
thing so object storage is GCS it's
awesome and I'm gonna talk briefly about
it it's not a requirement by any means
you can't say oh I can't move the cloud
because my workload doesn't work use
object storage or something to that
effect it doesn't it doesn't work that
way right we want to make sure the
matching is is great to your application
the other one is we don't want to look
at well look at those customers that are
on stage they used you know this storage
solution that's the one I have to use
well I mean you kind of completely
different applique
right so really I think we need to
ignore all that sort of hype and then
think about more just what are your
applications need right just focus on
the applications that you're running how
are they running today on what the
existing systems are and then what do
they need in the cloud so what can we
modernize and and where does innovation
and new things make sense and where does
just you know using what what you're
doing today it makes a lot of sense all
right so so GCS right GCS is awesome
people always ask well why aren't you
pushing people into GCS and the point is
is that well many applications just
don't fit the model and so the POSIX API
is one of them but even if you know you
put the AHS POSIX API on top of GCS
there's still a million other
requirements where object storage as a
concept in which it's been implemented
just doesn't fit right as long latency
times no in-place updates you know small
random reads you can be really tricky in
terms of how you're doing them and you
know you can always copy them into the
individual nodes and process them there
but if your data set is larger than what
you can process in a single VM you run
yourself into trouble as well so you
know let's go back to think about NFS
again and see if how that that that can
fit but you know talk to some people
that are like well NFS I I'd been using
an NFS and it's slow why are you telling
me to use NFS in the cloud I'm very
confused on this on this thing well the
point is is that NFS is modern it is
cloud friendly and it does work really
well there's no reason to dump you know
baby with the bathwater as they say you
know NFS is built into all of the VMS
you deploy it works very well with
kubernetes it's preemptable very
friendly in the sense that just take
your VM away right and if s already
stored your data somewhere and you know
in many ways it's very scalable you can
support tens of thousands of cores as
well as its familiar to your ite
administration staff and so that's
something where we really think we have
something that we can build upon problem
though is today NFS in the cloud I would
argue is in a very immature play
and we're really just at the beginning
of the journey to start thinking about
well maybe we don't need to do it
exactly the same way and maybe we need
to think about it in a slightly
different manner on how we're deploying
it on premise and ends our then when we
were on deploying it on premise and so
you know one of the things is open
source storage can be tricky right
talk about yak shaving there can be a
lot of yak shaving and unmanaged open
source solutions the vendor ecosystem is
growing and we're doing our best to
improve it
but it's still in its early stages and
that's where something becomes hard
because a lot of times you're having to
take a new chance on a new vendor inside
the cloud and in a lot of cases the
current NFS and file storage options
that you can deploy they were designed
for hardware and people are just doing
lifts and shifts into the the cloud and
they're not handling new failure models
performance characteristics and and how
the durability is managed and so it's
really something where we want to
rethink about let's use NFS but let's
rethink about how we're doing it so what
we want is file storage you know manage
and scale it just like the cloud does
but you know drive it like an enterprise
right we want to make sure that this is
enterprise ready so back to the point of
why does Google care though about about
this stuff this NFS stuff well you know
let's look at ETA industry you know the
industry was at eight point five billion
dollars it's growing over the next six
years to fourteen billion dollars and
that's just the software ecosystem
itself and so that's not including any
of the IT infrastructure underneath the
covers that's supporting it right and so
Google wants to be that IT
infrastructure that is supporting this
multi-billion dollar industry under the
covers and why we're working with people
like Naidu but that's just one of many
industries where we're seeing file as
dominant and the software vendors would
have to completely rewrite how they're
doing things today and it's not even
clear that it's possible even if they
wanted to and so manufacturing oil and
gas you know higher education research
financial services those quants that are
out there you know healthcare genomics
and a media of course that you'll see a
here as well and so all of these
industries are built on file today and
it's something where we believe that if
we can make file really easy and well
integrated into the cloud and this is
something that we Google cloud can
really leverage and so you know our
mission here at Google cloud is to make
file storage awesome and easy to use and
just a super cloud integrated as you
would expect and that's why we're so
excited to work with people like me I do
at the silicon who's really pioneering
how EDA can be done inside the cloud and
that's that's what I have back to you
Dave thank you very much so let's what I
wanted to do then is show what this
actually looks like and get out of the
slides a bit and show some action and as
brave as I am about doing live demos
it's one of my favorite things I
recorded these just for you so we can
get straight to the point and cover a
lot of topics in a short amount of time
so real briefly let me tell you a little
bit about Alaska file as you know we're
kind of a new company into the scene
came out of stealth mode last year we we
built a a full stack storage product as
an NFS filer designed to work with in
kind of cloud principles but still show
up like you're used to in enterprise
could the idea that Dean was talking
about where you know you're comfortable
living in in your enterprise home your
application is kind of built there and
it exists and the underlying
infrastructure is set we designed ours
to be compatible with that but also move
straight into cloud and I'll show you
what that looks like as we go so some
simple things that we allow you to do
one is just take high-performance NFS
applications and run them as is in cloud
all that all of these semantics work to
the way that you would expect I'll show
some of that in a bit but we should have
it show up inside of Google so your
applications can just lift shift and
start running second is we have some
capabilities to take advantage of the
different types of storage inside of
Google without forcing you to deal with
it so there's storage inside of compute
engine there's storage inside of cloud
storage and we have the ability to move
data back and forth and tear them
without breaking like POSIX semantics in
a single name
and and things like that that matter to
your applications and then lastly the
data mobility side of it we have a
capability called Cloud Connect that
moves fold like data sets we we take
snapshots of data and ship them as a
whole back and forth so you can keep
your data integrity intact but have it
show up and use it where you want it so
think about like giving lifts to data
sets that tend to have a lot of gravity
in them due to the nature of data so
these are the two components I'll be
talking about back and forth on on the
far side is the file system this is a
full stack scale-out file system so it
presents like an NFS server but it's
fully distributed it's a it's a shared
nothing write anywhere architecture so
we just as we need to scale capacity and
performance the scaling unit is a node a
little server and that you just they
just add dynamically laterally as you
need more and as you don't need it as
much you just extract or it constricts
backend so it's very elastic and it
actually works to add and take away on
demand and then in cloud cloud what's
magic about cloud is you can instantiate
anything at the drop of a hat so we can
stand up Onalaska file cluster in mere
minutes the kind of thing you wouldn't
do on Prem you wouldn't stand up a filer
at you know on a whim on an afternoon do
a project and then throw it away that's
typically a sixth five-year process
right that we can shrink it down into a
couple of minutes and then lastly Cloud
Connect is a companion technology as
part of our stack and this is about
reaching out to datasets that don't live
inside of a last file yet so Cloud
Connect can exist to connect to an
existing a filer whatever that might be
grab the data take a complete snapshot
of it that's identical to what you have
all the POSIX data and the only thing
about the namespace attributes hard link
soft links it keeps all that intact
compresses that deed oops it and moves
it into cloud storage and makes it ready
for action as a file system later ok so
that that's what Cloud Connect is I'm I
I didn't take time to add a demo of
Cloud Connect into this session we did
one yesterday that was fantastic that
I'll show you a link to and I encourage
you go on YouTube watch some videos
and you can contact us to download and
use this tool but essentially it's it's
a connection point between file
infrastructure and object
infrastructures you know objects are
designed to store files in a flat
namespace so to create hierarchy and
logic in an object system you have to do
that yourself essentially whereas a file
system shows up and it's ready to go I
can create folders and files and it all
kind of self organizes so Cloud Connect
bridges the gap between those worlds
instead of using objects as files each
object is essentially like a block and
then we can store chunks of files across
millions or billions of objects and
still maintain a namespace that allows
us to take many versions of a file
system as many as you like and you know
stored in the smallest compacted space
possible so we can do lots of versions
of snapshots compression and
deduplication for the tearing
capabilities that we have in the product
okay so take a look at that there's a
quick you know sneak peek at the
interface of you know different object
providers that it supports it's really
designed to go any from any source to
any target and be a middleman in between
them okay
so take a look this session happened
yesterday with Jerome
you can screencap that that link and go
watch it and there's a bunch of videos
on YouTube as well ok so let's move on
all right
so inside of Google Cloud there's
there's a couple of options for for NFS
there's a few and they're growing and
really briefly being announced just a
few weeks ago is is file store so I'm
not going to spend a lot of time on file
store but it's a fully managed you know
file system you can get a file system
mount pay-as-you-go and start using it
some it has you know kind of fixed
boundaries in terms of how big it gets
but it seems like a really great product
on our side where alasa file really fits
is for you know applications that need
any kind of really demanding problems to
solve whether it's demanding in terms of
capacity or performance or both and some
of that dynamic nature of those
applications so alas the file is
designed to kind of grow with you and
just you know to whatever the the
boundaries of your application may be
unlimited is kind of the term that we
use and we think about as we design an
architect alasa file okay and it's been
great to work closely with the Google
team and take advantage of some of the
you know the power of that
infrastructure underneath there really
stretch what we can do with this system
so a little bit more about ecfs is what
we call it a lasso file cloud filesystem
first of all like I said it's familiar
you're gonna find an NFS interface
that's suppose it's compatible other
protocols will probably introduce later
to make it even easier for you
second it's elastic truly scale out
scale in as your needs demand there's a
full API behind the product so every
function that we that we do you can
automate it behind your automation tool
of choice whatever that may be it's fast
so we're able to take advantage of
whatever underlying infrastructure we
attach to so we attach to raw disks
inside of our nodes and we can take
advantage of persistent disk persistent
SSD local SSD and even cloud storage and
then take advantage of those and make
them available as a single pool of
usable capacity okay
and so that that that that choice allows
us to get really cost-effective you can
match the the storage infrastructure to
the cost nature of whatever your problem
is and get the right amount of
performance out of it and change your
mind it's like an instantiate quickly
and tear it back down you can deploy 18
clusters a day it's all it's all good
it's flexible so you can the stuff can
show up where you need it you know
Google is always offering more and more
places to compute all around the world
we can follow them around and then
lastly the last two points I wanted to
drive home before we're jumping in the
demos 8 cloud native meaning this was
designed with the the semantics of cloud
in mind as opposed to that of on-prem
you know and the world is a lot
different you don't see the
infrastructure in the same way when
you're running in cloud the the
interrupts are different the failures
look different they're not hardware
failures we're dealing with our more
logical failure failures in the stack
and essentially you design expecting
failures to occur all the time so
they're different principles that you
have to bring to the table we've
designed for that and then lastly you
know Dean mentioned open-source versus
supported products you know we're a full
company supporting this product so 24 by
7 support continual updates when you're
enterprise into cloud you need that sort
of comfort to be wrap around it so
everything just works and you can meet
your SLA as we meet our SLA to you okay
all right so getting started I'm going
to show this working if you want to
start in fact if you're bored of my
presentation follow this link or go on
to cloud console look in the marketplace
search for a last file if you can't
remember how to spell that
search for NFS and you'll see two
options we have up in the marketplace
now we have our file system click deploy
as long as you have a project you can go
you'll be up and running answer a couple
questions and you'll be able to store
data in minutes and then below that
we're excited we just released this last
week is our storage provisioner this is
our connection into into kubernetes and
so if you have a kubernetes the gke
cluster running in cloud click but
button button and you're gonna be
deploying NFS storage to store stateful
data from your containers and I'll show
you a bit of that as well in fact your
own session I mentioned goes into a deep
dive on that topic yesterday ok but once
you're deployed you hit our console runs
right out a Google cloud and then any
application you have that needs this can
can just start working all right let's
show this stuff for not in action so
demo topology I'm working with today on
the top is as a projects inside a cloud
platform I have our file system deployed
I've got a few standard Linux clients
running on CentOS I have a google
kubernetes engine cluster running and
there are the that's already deployed
and then I'll be running different
applications from there Cloud Connect
connects the object and then lastly I
have an on-prem data center that's
connected through a VPN tunnel to to my
private project as well alright so
storage performance everyone talks about
performance I did a couple of
performance demos for you just to get
off that off the table we claimed to be
high performance storage and able to
meet the needs essentially where you are
so let me show you a couple different
profiles I thought might be interesting
and then I'll shift into some of the
functionality of how the stuff works out
there ok so 3 workloads ones uh you know
transaction IO IO is one type of a
workload you might think databases or
lots of small files lots of changes in
the like the last of all was designed to
be
a transactional file system we excel in
this area where a lot of other file
systems you would think this isn't what
you use NFS for I wouldn't put an Oracle
database on on NFS or my sequel or
something
here you can so the demo I'm going to
show you starts here so I'm running a
kubernetes environment on the on the top
you'll see I'm going to start adding
more and more containers and every one
that adds it's going quickly I'll go
back so you can see that a little faster
and then there we go so the demos will
go quick so as I add containers and
scale them you'll see performance down
here you got throughput measured in
megabytes to gigabytes per second you've
got iOS as how many transactions are
happening per second in thousands that's
a que and the latency is along the
bottom and then up on the right in the
corneal you see how many connections are
to the filesystem are so many NFS
connections are being instantiated so
our objective with this to show you that
that we can maintain a linear
performance profile as load as added to
the system so watch it one more time
here we go you see throughput going up
you see this is really an i/o driven
workload so that hit about about 300 or
so thousand iOS alright let's go to the
next one second profile large file
random reads so you have big bulk files
this might be median entertainment or
genomics or something where you have you
know these massive media or image files
that need to be loaded up quickly you
for processing whether that's for AI or
ml or something else like that we'll
show you how we do there
so watch the throughput here we're
trying to get two gigabytes per second
I'm time lapsing all of this to not bore
you with the details but this is about
ten minutes worth of loading and it hits
about 5.2 gigabytes per second in the
end so this is a small cluster this kind
of entry-level cluster if we need more
wood you see keep adding more what do
you want to get to ten 20 50 gigabytes
per second we can just keep on going
okay you'll see we only have 24
connections we're already pushing that
much IO
we're hitting we're hitting bottlenecks
inside of the kubernetes engine actually
where we need to keep adding
infrastructure to introduce more load to
this system lastly the opposite large
file writes so maybe I'm generating
large files images and the like I need
to push those quickly down into my
storage persistence layer how fast can I
do that
so same infrastructure here well let
this guy spin up you watch throughput
again so as we're adding more knows
we're pushing up to about a 10 gig
connection right about now so we found
we're at 1.1 so that ends up at about
1.2 or so which is essentially a full 10
gig connection so we found a saturation
point in that network so as performance
everyone talks about performance you got
to perform to play you can't qualify in
this business but that's one of many
things that matter when you're taking an
enterprise application to cloud alright
so deployments you know cloud is
typically designed to be click and go
and not worried about infrastructure so
this shows you here what a typical
deployment looks like with the last file
you click on the button select your
project tell it what Network you want to
write on and hit deploy ok you're still
using one finger so far essentially and
then it'll start rolling out if you've
ever used a ployment manager it's very
very typical here all the components
spin up on the far side or over here
you'll see it gives you unique
credentials you can use a login for the
first time this is our console or GUI
all of these functions again are
available through API it you tell it
what kind of stores you want to use
local SSD persistent SSD we've
she just added a few more options to
that list just in the last couple of
weeks and in no time
once you hit go this will spin up puts a
few VMS out there inside of your project
and then those services are now exposed
and available to all of the all of the
workloads you have running in cloud ok
that's it that takes about five minutes
and it's all done in fact if you're into
automation infrastructure is code things
like terraform or ansible and puppet we
have options there for you as well we've
got a we've got a terraform essentially
a cookbook out on github you can go
follow that link to grab it or grab a
solution article out of our website on
how to do this in fact I'll show you in
less than 60 seconds here and we'll let
this demo go assuming this one will play
for us that one is not playing let's see
if we can get it go alright it is so
fast you can't even see it
you're gonna see what you would have
seen is a lot of code flying through the
screen you give it a cookbook you tell
you what your parameters are and it
deploys it and when you're done it goes
and destroys it and cleans up all of its
mess from from before ok next the
storage provisioner works this is one
we're excited about we just launched
this if you have kubernetes which is you
know containers are designed to be
totally stateless but you find it old
applications not all the traditional
apps or in databases than the like you
want to run as containers and get the
benefit of compute have it they have a
hard time dealing with state you know
you can store data to a local machine
but it's challenging when you get into
tens or hundreds or thousands of
containers and they were need to work
off a common data set this is what this
is what we're designed for here using
standard NFS which comes out of the box
working with a container platform and
this allows you to connect it right into
kubernetes add a storage class it will
show up as a lasso file inside of gke
and now it's a resource where you can do
you can do provisioning write to us
straight from you know coop CTL ok so
there's a concept inside of a lasso file
called data container so a data
container is two files and data what
pew container is to your applications
it's a it's a bucket or contains
everything as a file system or a single
namespace that you can then manage as a
single entity so a container is where
where we apply policies to to your data
underneath the cover things like how
much storage does it need we have
services like dee doop and compression
built into that and so this demo will
show the creation of a data container
log into the console
there's your dashboard and all the fancy
storage stuff capacities performance we
hit the data container screen you see a
bunch of DC's in here point-and-click
give it a name we'll be using this one
in the next couple of demos we'll turn
on turn on off you get toggled e-tip
compression on anytime you like and then
we set a size okay it's a dynamic size
but this is what will show up the
filesystem expects to see a size when
you connect to your machine okay so
that's it it's created get some syntax
to connect to it at the standard mount
again there's no client side stuff
needed standard in a facet of a VM works
so then that's what it looks like
behind the scenes you can see the layers
of policies of different features we can
add in replication snapshots NFS exports
and other features will continually add
with our engineering team and Israel
will start to show up into here as we
continue down our journey and cloud ok
you'll see down on the bottom the
ability to do user mappings this is NFS
language here if you're used to the NFS
this is very familiar to you so here
we're gonna you know export this share
make it available to just the machines
inside of my private network and now
we're ready to go that's now being
exposed and advertised and ready for a
consumption ok so let's see it at work
I got a machine Linux host again the
message I'm trying to drive home is this
should be normal right I I do a show
mount and I can see the the exported
files systems off of that machine I'm
gonna make a directory in Mountain one
got it move into it there's nothing in
there let me copy some data in
so standard commands copying data over
these things can be more difficult with
cloud storage very easy with NFS all
right so I'm going to look at a file so
I'm showing file ownership ACLs this is
POSIX information you know file
ownership all of the attributes we
maintain all of that intact m time a
times c time ACLs everything works we
just changed it it's you know the
integrity is there and just works ok
look familiar
bingo next topic what about resizing
what if I need to change that coming out
of storage world if you've done work
within San this is always a big problem
any block based systems the nice thing
about NFS is you can change your mind
really quickly without really any sort
of an impact so to make the change
either go into the GUI or throw a
command through the API give it a new
size we go from 10 gigabytes here to 2
thousand gigabytes update it and that's
already then propagated to the VM you
know we'll do a DF again you'll see
right on the bottom we went from 10
gigabytes here to 2 terabytes available
easy answer to I'm running out of
capacity as a problem for the end user
in fact we can vastly over provision the
system we'll just do this one to be cute
we'll go from 2 terabytes to 20
terabytes we can move into a petabyte
range if we wanted to right so kind of
create your destiny the way you want it
and then let your you can let your
capacity the actual allocation doesn't
have to be made until you start running
out of capacity so I could have a three
terabyte cluster that grows into into
those sizes ok snapshots snapshots are
amazing if you use them right in
development process for whatever reasons
restoring files or you know keeping
multiple versions of a database or
something we've built that right into
the system here so I'll show you a
manual way to take a snapshot and again
same caveat this can all be automated
through API calls or other command line
functions so snapshots in place
I think we are on the other demo let me
skip ahead all right
I don't have the snapshot one in but
snapshots take we use the dot snapshot
directory at the root of every export so
all the snapshots that are taken there
are then made available and those
snapshots can then you can access them
and mount them directly or you can
replicate those off to another site like
I'll show you here and the second
alternative is to use Cloud Connect to
mount a snapshot and move that data to
other platforms like GCS so a quick
sneak peek if you have to Alaska file
systems or more setup we can create a
replication relationship a synchronous
replication to other sites so this is
this this would be used if you have an
Alaska file on Prem I can use this to
connect through a VPN tunnel to Google
Cloud and I can replicate data up there
and make it accessible and the like okay
and we can go bi-directional and all of
that all right so there's a quick
overview of the tech and all the
capabilities in there there's a lot more
than that but I wanted to again drive
the point home that we're trying to
create a place almost like you know a
hotel experience it's a home away from
home as you start to figure out how am I
going to get into cloud so I want to now
hand the mic over to Naidu he's been
leading the team over there at the East
silicon for many years a pioneer in
their industry and they've been you know
breaking glasses they figured out how to
take advantage of of cloud in the EDA
space so without further ado Naidu thank
you
you know a silicon is an advanced to the
chip and IP provider for Tier one
systems like a Cisco subdiv all for
Ifill formance computing networking data
city you know the AI and Phi G markets
you know so we've been in business since
2000 developed over 300 chips into
production and our current focus is on a
FinFET you know leading-edge 16
nanometer and below so current you know
the ongoing work is on the seven
nanometer staff that is the bleeding
edge
and so these our unique capabilities are
you know so we are only supplier in the
world we found the agnostic we don't
care whether research TSMC are Samsung
we have chips in both foundries and we
use big data to optimize the chip design
before even the design starts we
estimate big data based on our hundreds
of terabytes of data the IP libraries so
what is the optimal power performance
and area so that's our unique
capabilities and differentiation in the
marketplace so you know Dean and they
have talked about you know Google
compute and storage right so what are
the business challenges that we are
trying to address so in chip design
right during the tape out phase typical
compute and storage requirements are 2
to 4x more so we have on our private
cloud about 12,000 course doing this
ient designs but one of the chips that
required about 30,000 course
six months before they tape out so about
a year ago
you know we partnered with Google to see
that rather than going and building
another 30,000 more cores which is more
expensive we already went into data
center as a service about three years
ago and you know there is no capex to
build right so is we are in effects
model but the current issue with the
current provider is that every time we
need more capacity they need a long-term
commit that's not going to scale given
the technology that we are in 7 and 14
so partnered with Google and the other
challenge we have was you know so when
you are close to the tape out you cannot
rewrite over flows design flows this
takes years right so for us the current
design flow we built it over the 18
years so it means that within six months
window we need to scale from 10,000
cores to the 20,000 more cores and the
last one is that you know our IP
development is always one load ahead and
their computer requirements again is
exponentially higher to several thousand
coats from few hundred 2,000 course so
let's see how we did it no this is a
truly hybrid cloud on the our engineers
we have 700 engineers around the world
come to our data center to do there you
know the normal flow using the same UI
and so that that's why they come to the
layout and run their jobs they don't see
anything on the right side we have
configured a couple of Q's 1g Internet
connection through the VPN for the NFS
traffic to the Google Cloud and 100 back
line for the administrator like you know
starting the VMS starting the jobs and
so forth so one of the attractive thing
on the Google side was you know Google
come has a concept called preemptable
VMs that comes with no commitment the
80% discount than the regular viens that
was very attractive to us when we
started the journey and we engineered
such that you know the chip development
is you know one of the chip that we
targeted this the way 30,000 30,000
cores are needed for the chip we tap out
the storage is about seven hundred
terabytes one chip so we possibly cannot
have that right so that's where you know
the center is based file system over a
year ago it was it was not scaling
that's when we partnered with the dance
company were able to use their elastic
file and you know in the hybrid cloud
truly whatever the results are they it
locally stored and syncing back to the
results to the small subset to the
private cloud the other business unit
where we have the chip develop the IP
development we don't use any local
storage is completely remote NFS they
are small thousands of course even now
we are running several thousand cords
continuously the results are enough
remote NFS to our private cloud again
90% of the workloads are used Google's
parent of all VMs so with respect you
know Dave talked about you know lots of
slides lot of lots of demos in one
project we were about to 8 node cluster
with a couple of hundred terabytes and
the other project three node cluster so
it scales the guy David you know is the
key architect on our site closely worked
with the day 1 team but you're also the
the whole thing took from p+ production
deployment within three months we were
able to scale from zero to twenty
thousand course one business unit and
business in it another 10,000 course
it's in three months time frame you know
so what are the some of the lessons
learned you know during those three
months BOC process the MBK at the PD
case and tools these are all terabytes
of data so we cannot be remote enough s
so we have a local storage on the file
system in the Google cloud the other one
is that you know on Prem we are able to
you know the results that is where some
of the customization is needed this
terabytes of data cannot be back and
forth even if you have a 10 gig 100 big
client right so we modified our float to
only small subset of the data to be
synced back to the private cloud and
storage is still expand so your Google
knows and these guys are on the cloud so
we only very aggressive in cleaning up
the data rather than keeping it for
months
so because the intermediate results are
only kept for a week or so and then the
actual results a small subset is synced
back to our private cloud ok the other
thing is that the way it stands on the
cloud for a chip design or complex
design like ours physical disks won't
work the SSDs we learned longer we
started with the physical disk
it wasn't scaling then we had to go with
all SSDs and then you know like we
talked about right NFS traffic is on a
separate line and then the
administrative traffic is on a different
line these are the key lessons learned
and we are even given today we are the
only company that does the full physical
design on the cloud
yeah we really appreciate that
that presentation idea that was a fun
project to work on together and very
impressive what we could do
30,000 cores just like that right and
what are you doing with those cores now
other great things yeah they're being
reused somewhere else
that's amazing right I'm the ability to
spend sand up an infrastructure that big
and that complex and that short amount
of time and then only pay for what you
use is pretty impressive and that's
really it's I think cloud form I'm
seeing with a customer base out there
and different companies it's just
changing the way that you work all right
the the fundamentals are different so I
can I can do short-term things as needed
pay for exactly what I need and get you
know really customized all right it's
it's kind of a lot of bespoke
opportunities in cloud but it's also
becoming a nice place to rest as your
final home if you will and run
applications out there so I wanted to do
a shout out to one of our team members
you don't know him but you should his
name is Ronan Cowan he's one of the
wizards it'll last the file that did a
lot of the work to make these demos come
together for us this is a dress code at
Alaska file by the way you must wear
pointy Kona hats lastly to bring it all
back together you know no yak shaving
right now I can't say that there won't
be any of course there will be that's
what we do is our jobs but what we're
trying to do is take yet another bunch
of labor out of the process to get into
cloud things that really don't create a
lot of value building out file systems
and learning how to do ZFS or whatever
it might be just doesn't add a lot of
value to the bottom line when your boss
or your business or your organization is
saying I need to get to the financial
benefits of cloud I need time matters
money matters let's move we're trying to
take those things out of the way so you
can move faster again going back to what
Dean said it's not about the hardware
and the and the protocol right that
though they're actually agnostic you can
use them in cloud it's about let's use
them the right way and we can move
faster so it's all about acceleration
what we're trying to do is present an
opportunity to make it easy to lift and
shift or
burst or don't you know move permanently
into cloud and be able to take some of
the the applications that really demand
a lot more than is typical in my career
over the last 15 20 years the early
adopters in cloud were mostly either
pure web applications or secondary
storage and dr and backup and things
like that i think the world is really
shifted right we can do full production
high performance workloads really
intense stuff and I think cloud is
starting to meet not only the you know
the functional requirements but the
security requirements to get there as
well
so remember alas to file cloud native
NFS single click let it go follow the
link on the bottom and the in the
marketplace and you can get started
today thank you come see us we're over
in the and the Mosconi south
I stopped by I've got a whole team over
there we'd love to chat with you some
more ok thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]